climate change on the planet Earth is
not real but if it is real it's not
man-made but if it is man-made maybe
it's actually good and we'll show you
why come on
[Music]
the planet Earth home to the world's
most exotic creatures and some of our
favourite timeshares 97% of scientists
believe the climate is changing but we
know it's not our fault the head of the
Environmental Protection Agency Scott
Pruett even says climate change might be
good we know that humans have most
flourished during times of what warming
trends and that's amazing
because we find recycling to be boring
and actually sort of tacky so do you
travel in style to the Savannah Georgia
to prove Scott through it right and
ensure we never have to change our
totally reasonable extravagant life
signs
our first step in the wild and elegant
meal of oysters with an ecologist named
Daniel Harris so what's the big deal
Daniel like what is bad about climate
change well temperatures increasing and
one of the consequences of that is that
we have more intense storms and more
frequent storms we've been playing this
blame game about climate change and a
lot of its falling on humans is there
anything on human that's causing this
there's a study that has shown that
oysters can in one instance at least has
been shown to release a lot of methane
which is a greenhouse gas methane is
that's like farting sure so you're
telling me that boy stirs are causing
climate change no it's crazy that
they're entirely to blame even though
oysters filter seawater and protect
shorelines we know that they are
responsible for our changing planet
their parks items humans are simply not
to blame at least that's what dr. oyster
farts said that's not exactly what I
said but it's how I understand it boy
stur is just like you and I exhale
greenhouse gases but that's been going
on for millions of years there has been
a dramatic change and that is jus to
human industrialization it just seems
crazy because if like oyster activity
contributes to climate change at all but
also hurts them it'd be insane not to
check
their lives are in danger their homes
are in danger what are they doing
dr. fart was flummoxed but we'll clear
it up methane represents 10 percent of
u.s. greenhouse gas emissions but if you
zoom in you see that only 0.9% is from
other methane sources which includes
oyster parts
so if we zoom way the hell in on just
that slice then it's clear it's a
massive part of the pie I mean dang it
takes up the whole screen feeling
vindicated we traversed the Savannah
Georgia relishing the fact that climate
change isn't real but if it is real it's
not man-made
in fact we're helping so we went to see
this fragile farty ecosystem guided by
marine ecologist ELISA caiman right now
we're out in the marsh right behind you
there is an oyster reef so I actually
study a crab that lives in the
interstitial spaces within the oyster
reef I study the parasite that infects
this crab to do
it's a barnacle and it gets into the
crab and actually cast rates and
feminised as the crab weight this
particle comes in and chomps their dicks
off that's not quite like that is there
anything that can stop these dick eating
parents what can we do my god so my
research actually shows that the
parasite is more sensitive to climate
change than its host
so as temperatures are increasing the
parasite may actually be removed from
the host population here in Georgia wait
climate change might help kill these
parasites that may happen the parasite
may be removed climate change could save
these crab sticks they could stop this
kasparek climate change is good
Wow turn the boat around
that could die Alissa's research proves
it climate change is not real but if it
is real it's not man-made but if it is
man-made then maybe it's actually good
time to see these crabs and their weeny
gobbling parasites up close in their
beautiful habitat the ground is grass
she showed us the crabs who owe their
lives even more their dicks to climate
change so this one actually looks like
it has six sticks yeah so those are eggs
oh no this one has two little pinching
dicks yeah up front these here are also
its legs no Alyssa this one's actually
staring at me with two dicks if you were
to turn it over you can see its little
bean
yeah that's where the parasite is
scientists predict the earth will warm
to degrees by the end of the century
which is enough to kill off this dick
eating parasite once and for all
thus saving the depressed one perhaps
worse amendment penis and sure the
temperature increase could wipe out
coastal regions make parts of the world
uninhabitable and kill millions of
people due to catastrophic weather and
famine but crab dicks seems like climate
change is a good thing yeah it could be
for this individual crab but at a
broader scale there are many other
issues that we would need to think about
you know like I'm seeing some of my eyes
right now that's really good and you're
describing that solving stuff so I mean
just because we can't see it right now
it doesn't mean it's not happening Santa
would we be doing a piece on crab dicks
if it weren't you know we were serious
seriously pumped that we'd proven that
climate change was irrefutable good
thanks dr. dick and professor fart this
called for some diesel-powered foam
this is the circle-jerk of life
boisterous fart crab dicks are saved
politicians deny climate change and foot
soldiers like us help peddle the facts
we prefer to help continue this
beautiful cycle until the world gets
destroyed and we all turned to Stardust
but who cares if the world gets
destroyed we'll be dead by then and do
you know the best part what Josh I'll
tell you it's that planet Earth and
every crab dick and oyster fart on it
was all created by our bearded Caucasian
God
[Music]